Dominique Bernard était professeur de
français il a été tué de plusieurs coups
de couteau ce matin dans la cour de son
établissement d'aras le collège lycée
Gambetta au cris d'Allah Akbar un agent
de l'établissement le chef cuisinier est
encore entre la vie et la mort et un
autre enseignant a été blessé à 11h on
avait cours et on est dans le couloir
mil la sonnerie son B au début on pense
que c'est un un exercice du coup bah ça
nous inquiète pas trop t que ça commence
à rentrer dans une classe auice parce
que B on avait pas notre prof il était
pas encore là quelques instants plus
tard on reçoit des des vidéos comme quoi
on voit que il y a vraiment un mec un
fou qui plte des gens on a fermé à clé
on a fermé les volets barricad et les
Pors il il y en a qui ont ont commencé à
se stressé un peu pleurer mais on a
gardé Not Not inè Kat et Mohamed sont en
5e ils étaient en route pour la cantine
quand un prof est arrivé la bouche en
sang c'était notre prof de sport raconte
Ines à notre envoyé spécial il a crié
appelé la police derrière lui il y avait
un mec avec un ciseau ou un couteau
c'était un ancien élève je crois
l'assaillant Mohamed M a rapidement été
interpellé et placé en garde à vue à
11h9 il est fichier s et faisait l'objet
d'un suivi actif récent de la DGSI de
nationalité russse et d'origine tatenne
l'homme de 20 ans né en 2003 était
arrivé en France à 6 ans avec sa famille
il est un ancien élève du lycée où
l'attaque a eu lieu un professeur de PS
qu' l'a connu lorsqu'il était en
terminale le décrit comme un élève
réservé calme c'était vraiment un élève
lambda derrière cette façade Mohamed m
était connu des renseignements
territoriaux pour son islamisme radical
et était sur écoute depuis cet été il
avait été contrôl jeudi hier ces
conversations téléphoniques n'avaient
pas mise en évidence ces derniers jours
d'éléments permettant d'annoncer un
passage à l'acte sa famille avait fait
l'objet d'une tentative d'expulsion en
2014 alors installée à Rennes elle avait
été réveillée le 19 février au petit
matin par la police aux frontière pour
être expulsé vers Moscou raconé France 3
région Bretagne mais la mobilisation de
plusieurs associations dont le MRAP la
simade et la RESF avaient fait échouer
l'opération l'un de ses frères a été
interpellé à l'été 2019 par la DGSI dans
le cadre d'un projet d'attentat déjoué
puis de faê d'apologie et été croé après
l'attaque de ce matin un autre membre de
la fraterie âgé de 17 ans a été
interpellé alors qu'il se trouvait à
proximité d' d'un autre établissement
cette attaque est-elle liée à
l'actualité israélienne aucune
revendication n'est connue à ce jour le
parquet national antiterroriste s'est
saisi de l'affaire et a ouvert une
enquête pour assassinat en relation avec
une entreprise terroriste cette attaque
intervient presque 3 ans jour pour jour
après l'assassinat de Samuel pati
l'enseignant de 47 ans décapité le 16
octobre 2020 près de son collège des
Yvelines après avoir montré à ses élèves
des caricatures de Mohamed lors d'un
cours sur la liberté d'expression c'est
à nouveau dans une école que frappe le
terrorisme et dans un contexte que nous
connaissons tous au sein de cet
établissement scolaire qui a été frappé
une fois encore par la barbarie du
terrorisme islamiste et je veux
évidemment avoir une penser avant tout
pour cet enseignant qui aujourd'hui a
été lâchement et sauvagement assassiné
sa famille et pour la famille des des
deux
blessés